こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです!
よだれが出た
皆さんはタトゥーというものを知っていますか?
芸術のでも一環かもしれないですよね
そこはよくわかんないし
やってみようとも思わないんですけども
いざやると実家に帰れなくなるので
できません
やっちゃうと実家に帰れなくなるので、タトゥーは僕はできないんですけどもー
こんな僕でもちょっとタトゥーを感じることができるアイテムを見つけました
こちらです
「TATTOO　Fronties goldmetal tattoo stickers」(言い方むちゃくちゃ)
あーーー　every girl use it
タトゥーシールでございます
すぐ貼れるみたいなんですけども
これをちょっと今日はね、実際に身体に貼ってみようと思います
が!!!!
多分これだけタトゥーシールがあれば、多分全身タトゥーになると思うんすよ
これ、全身タトゥーつったらもう恐怖そのもんですからねー
全身タトゥーの人に会ったことある!?
ないない
怖いべ!?
俺YouTubeで動画見たけど怖いべ
やっ、なんかもうほんとになんか、不思議なんすよ
僕もちょっとそういう怖い感じの人になってみようかなと、思いまして
っそ、怖い感じで、ちょっと今日はピザを!!頼んでみようと、思います
濡れた布やスポンジで
あっ!　濡れた布やスポンジが必要だ
うぅい!!
おぉぁあー!!!
っはははは(笑)
濡れた布やスポンジを持ってきたので
これで出来ますね
早速やろう
これ難しくね?　けっこう
まずー、切り取らなきゃいけないの!?
そうそう
おいおいおいおいおいおい
こうしてー
で、こう。
こーゆーこと?
んじゃない?
あ、じゃあもうすでにぬ、え?と、ね?
こう?
ちゃ、えぇ?違うよ
え!?
ぅわぁお
で、どうすればいいの?
えぇ!?　逆じゃないの?
ほらぁ
あ、ほんとだ
ほらほらほら
おぉ～!!　すげすげすげ
うーぉおーー!
うぅぉあーー!!
こうゆうことだ
なるほどな!
すげぇ、なんかおばあちゃん家みたいな匂いするね、これ
あ、わかる!　タンスの裏か、タンスの、タンスにゴンゴンみたいな匂い
ま、でもいいんじゃないすか?
よし、じゃあちょっと全部を貼って行きましょう
あ～、ちょ待ってこれやばい、これけっこう冷たい
うわぁ!
これすごいよ!
すっげぇ!
これすごくねぇ!?　けっこう
うわぁあああ!!!!
ああああああ!!!!
ぅわおぅ!
wwww
っね、ホモホモしいでしょ(笑)
完全ホモビデオだから(笑)
おぉ～!!!
やばいじゃん!　ヤンキーじゃん!
wwwww
なーにぃ?
やんのかぁ?　おめぁ?
卍(まんじ)
はい!　全部のタトゥーをつけると大体、こんな、感じになりま～す
なんかいかついんですけど、実際こうゆう人動画で見たことあるんでいるん、、かもしれないんすよー
タトゥー入れすぎちゃったいかついお兄さんでも、ピザが普通に注文できるのか
ちょっと、検証してみようと、思います
もうすぐ、ピザ屋さんが来るので少々、お待ちください
ちょい、やばくない?
おぁあ～、卍(まんじ)～
いぇえあ!!
どんなヤンキーだよ、それ(笑)
おぁあ～、卍(まんじ)～
怖い!　ほんとに怖い!
卍(まんじ)～
飛んできそう!
っちょ、怖い!
うわっ、うわっっ!!　え～っ!!　うわぁ!!
マジ卍(まんじ)(笑)
wwwww
マジ卍(まんじ)だぜ～
痛ッッ!!　大怪我した(笑)
…お待たせいたしましたー。
失礼いたしますー。
先に商品の方をお持ちいたします。
こちらにサインの方お願いいたします。
ありがとうございます
下の方が熱くなっておりますのでお気をつけください。
会計が2754円になります。
…じゃあ3000円でー
はい。
ありがとうございます。じゃ、お預かりします。
先に領収書の方、お渡しします。
はい
失礼します。
246円です。
はい
お返しします。
…#◎%☆$ですね…
wwwなんか、極道とかの…
あ、ありがとうございます!!
246円のお返しです。
ありがとうございます(笑)
またお待ちしています。
すぃやせん、ありがとうございます!
すいません、ありがとうございました!
あざぁっす!
失礼しまーす。
…卍(まんじ)!!